Farmer Jen is a vegetable grower
and divides the land he owns into broccoli
and spinach.
Last year he grew up
6 tons of broccoli per acre
and 9 tons of spinach
by acre,
of a total of 93 tons of vegetables.
This year he grew up
2 tons of broccoli per acre
and 3 tons of spinach
by acre
of a total of 31 tons of vegetables.
How many acres of broccoli and how many acres
with spinach farmer Jen?
Let's think about it.
The number of acres with broccoli
we will denote by B,
and the acres with spinach
we will indicate with S.
How many broccoli he raised over them,
say last year?
Last year how many broccoli did you raise?
Let's save it.
Last year.
It is told us that last year he raised 6 tons
broccoli from acre land.
If he raised 6 tons of broccoli per acre
and has B acres,
this will be 6 tons
on B acres.
He raised 6B tonnes of broccoli last year.
And by the same logic, how much spinach did you raise?
9 tonnes of sparkling acres per acre.
9S tons of spinach.
We also have a total of 93 tons,
we have a total of 93 tons of vegetables.
This will be equal to 93.
Let's look at them this year.
In general, when you decide on the task, do the following:
established variables altogether
for what you are looking for, and then look
how can you use the information given to us?
This year how many broccoli did he raise?
2 tons of broccoli
by acre.
It has the same number of acres. We can assume it is.
2 tons per acre on B acres
will be 2B tonnes of broccoli.
And by the same logic we will have,
that he had raised 3 tons of spinach per acre.
There is S acre.
Grows 3 tons
spinach from each acre, we will have 3S tons of spinach.
And we are told how many vegetables we have in common.
We have a total of 31 tons of vegetables.
This will be equal to 31.
We received a system of two equations
with two unknowns that we can use to find B and S.
What do we want to find first?
What we can do, let me transcribe the above equation.
We have 6B plus,
plus 9S is equal
of 93.
And the second equation,
let's try to eliminate B.
Let's multiply the second equation by minus 3.
I will multiply the left side by minus 3
and I will multiply the right side too
minus 3.
What do I get?
Minus 3 at 2B is minus 6B.
That's why we've multiplied it
minus 3.
Minus 3 at 3S is minus 9S,
minus 9S.
And then minus 3 at 31
will be minus 93.
What we get if we now get together
of the equations?
On the left side, 6B minus 6B is 0.
9S minus 9S, this is also 0. We will only get 0.
On the right side we get 93 minus 93.
This will also be 0.
This is the case where we get 0 is equal to 0,
which will be true no matter what x and y are.
This system is
with an infinite number of decisions.
It has infinite,
an infinite number of decisions.
We can say,
that these two conditions
do not give us enough information.
There are an infinite number of combinations of B and S,
which will satisfy these equations,
so we have not been given enough information,
to say exactly how much B and S.
Not enough
information!
I will put an exclamation mark there.